time to join this session the topic of
my session is safety in chatting cows in
particular how to form realistic failure
hypothesis if you look back in the
industry in the information technology
space in particular the concept of chaos
engineering is about 10 years old it's
not too long ago that we actually
started talking about this discipline
and these unlike other disciplines in an
engineering whether it's safety Public
Safety health care hospital systems you
know incident responses publicly for
like fire and police different
industries in addition engineering were
focused on safety of people and
equipment and human life they had a much
more longer runway on on how to do this
better I think in the case of software
engineering we are still getting used to
that idea we'll like hearing stories
about how different companies have
succeeded in breaking things and purpose
and how what kind of value they got out
of it so but in but instead I want to
talk about what might actually happen in
the real world these things don't go as
expected
your Carolinian programs might face will
face in fact some roadblocks you will
have to justify why you're doing it you
will have to justify why this matters at
all and so instead of talking about how
that worked out great what kind of tools
and technologies you can use I want to
spend the next 30 40 minutes I'm talking
about what could go wrong what are the
kind of stumbling blocks you hit and how
do you deal with those stumbling blocks
and then talk about some some some
lessons learned if I were to focus on
one topic today I won't take away from
this topic I want to give it up friend
is that it is all about learning from
incidents it's not about breaking things
on purpose it's more about learning from
incidents and that's what I'm going to
talk a lot about in this talk so my name
is subbu alam Raju I'm a vice president
of technology at Xperia Group
where I joined three and half years ago
leading the the cloud migration from
data centers to the public cloud so I
spent a lot of time thinking about
resilient architectures how to get
things right on the cloud how to operate
safely and securely and and cheaply on
the cloud so as part of that I spent a
kind of amount of time understanding how
to improve resiliency and I'm gonna pose
I have my Twitter handle there and I'm
gonna post my slides in a week or so at
my blog subbu dot org in fact they're
also you find some prior material on
this subject and previous talks I gave
and as well as at the material I
published on that feel free to check it
out it's very relevant to the talk that
I'm doing today so let me start with the
very definition of Kairos engineering
because I want to pull it out in the
context so that we know what we're
talking about chaos engineering is the
discipline of experimenting on a system
in order to build confidence in the in
its ability to withstand turbulent
conditions in production I want to say
this explicitly because there is still
material out there that describes cows
engineering as something that is
breaking things on purpose breaking
things randomly like tearing service off
cutting network down things like that
instead think of cows donating as a
discipline of making calculated
hypothesis of what might happen if you
do a break a certain do a certain
actually the disturb this disruptive
like turning off a server cutting a
network or introducing latency what
happens so it's about making hypotheses
and testing it it's like a bee testing
more different you make a hypothesis or
a control you put test hypotheses and
decide whether the hypothesis is right
or or not right so I use a simple visual
mental visual model to explain this even
even in end in simpler terms imagine a
system in a stable condition this is
your production systems or whatever it
is
it's a operating in a stable condition
you introduced a turbulence to it
and you make an assumption of the fault
is not your fault claim is that there is
where this vertical arrow is that means
if you tip the system the system up to
until the point the system will come
back to your stable condition that's
hypothesis you're making and if that
happens that is the case the system will
come back to the stable state all is
good but if your assumption of your
fault boundary is not right let's
imagine the fall boundary somewhat
before the turbulence then you broke the
system so basically with chaos meaning
you're testing that hypothesis you're
making it better and testing it in their
life so as you go through the rest of
the talk I won't do you think of four
questions what is the system is it just
your software your configuration your
databases your service network storage
and so on and so forth or does it all
include the people processes and tools
keep it in your back of mind because
when you say system it is not just the
software that is running on source it
includes the people that are operating
the system the process the tools the
second question how do you form
hypothesis you copies what the work of
other PR the teams or the companies that
have done would they work for you or not
how do you ensure safety so that you're
not pushing the system towards beyond
its its fall domains and then why should
it even listen to you that this work is
important this work is valuable so it is
important to allocate time and resources
to get this work done how do you make a
case for this kind of work keep that in
mind because why break something if it
is working that's how we deal with
software right all the time we don't
introduce new features if it is working
same thing why do you bother every
system is working keep those in mind so
let me take a step back
talk about a typical for a it is in fact
he's also my foray into this discipline
of why you think of cows engineering at
all in the first place it in my case
started with a cloud adoption which is
probably the case for a lot of you here
that you started off in cloud you are
disrupting breaking down your monoliths
you started outing microservices you put
the latest and greatest of cloud native
technologies and things are going well
you're picking up agility you're
releasing more frequently production and
then you get into a reasonable enough
complexity and size and scale and you're
actually serving real customers and
that's when you start to think about how
do I build resiliency because you start
to notice but the changes you're
introducing sometimes your outages
sometimes things are taking time and you
are end up carrying pages of the
weekends and you use not to get worried
about all these alerts you don't know if
you should get all the alerts or turn
them off sometimes you have cloud
failures like the AZ failure or ten days
ago in u.s. East one and so these things
happen you start to worry about how do I
actually get a handle of all this stuff
so I can build more resilient software
and then not worry about pager duty
anymore and that's when you realize oh
the resistant called chaos engineering
it's a light bulb that goes on your mind
that's what happened to me about two
years ago uh-huh I could actually start
investing in this field so you read
about it you look at all the tools out
there you look at all the success
stories you get excited about it it's
actually sort of interesting to do it
and then you get a bit of rush doing
that because you are actually
introducing failures in DL systems and
you can actually brag about it but then
the reality hits you you go and talk to
your teams
hey we're actually releasing this thing
in production I guess okay so no no
don't hit us because you'll find some
people saying goes let's do it
excited about it but a lot of people
that say don't touch our systems because
we have this mission-critical stuff
going on or we have this mainly release
that we are doing in the next six months
so don't bother us with this crap right
now because we got to get that done this
happens a lot this happen
to me and I'm sure they happened to a
lot and so you end up whitelist
disabling all those applications from
your monkey exercises and then you
realize this one you because you start
killing randomly service you realize
that it's actually not uncovering really
major stuff it's uncovering maybe Tyrael
stuff because you exclude all the things
that will break so you really are
limited with the benign things that you
want to break and they'll they look fine
probably they're in some cloud formation
auto-scaling groups and so they come
back app you are not worried about it
and in fact this what happened in our
case because over a period of time I was
noticing what's going on is that we
found cases where there was some a mice
that were deleted by five mistakes by
someone the auto scaling group failed
when I serve was taken down those are
the kind of bugs we found nothing
spectacular nothing magical it's sort of
bugs that you have in your automation
and then of course you can't and won't
test more serious failures because if
you turn off database I was do you know
that stuff is going to fall apart you're
not going to try region fellows because
you're not sure if there are
dependencies between your data centers
and you know go to blackhole systems
because you know there are critical
systems that detect so a lot of other
applications she's not actually testing
and more serious failures he sort of
stuck in this limbo that wanting to do
more but not sure how to make progress
that's one is begin to doubt your theory
without your your your idea of using
this technology this discipline to
actually improve resiliency this what
happened to me and then you get into the
valley of misery you don't know what to
do how do you get out of it this is
where I have my hypothesis is that my
observation is that a number of
counseling programs and I there because
you hit the reality the examine
excitement is over you got stuck in the
valley of despair so how do you get out
of it let's wipe the slate clean and
imagine a null hypothesis so very
standard technique in
let's imagine that chaos engineering has
nothing to do with systems capability to
withstand turbulent conditions in
production and let's find proof evidence
that actually disproves this hypothesis
how do you do that we do that by
changing the question from how do we
make the system withstand turbulent
conditions to how is the system actually
behaving today in production it shift
from area from how do I fix the problem
to let's understand the problem very
simple technique very simple basic but
then how do you understand what is going
on the production today you can look at
the as design state of the system the as
design is typically your documentation
your diagrams of the architecture your
code tells you the design state your
matrix your logs and alerts they all
tell you as design state none of them
are complete they're all incomplete
piece of information that you can gather
about something that is running in
production imagine ten thousand
applications in there in a in an
enterprise and you have no idea what
those ten thousand are doing you have
some ideas of vague ideas of which part
is doing what and you probably are
familiar with some of them but not all
of them so you in complete understanding
of what's turning in production so
basically the you as design state is
biased towards what we think is running
in the production in fact the matrix and
alerts and logs we will we do are
reflecting the same bias that we have
about how it is supposed to work not how
it is working because that's a starting
point so it's no good to look at the as
design state because it doesn't tell you
much about what is actually happening in
production instead you look at the as it
is thing how is the a how in the system
actually working in production today how
do you do that you look at incidents
because incidents are the real world
they tell you what is going on in
production and they tell you how your
so architecture is working or not
working they tell you how your tools and
processes are working or not working
they tell you how your people are
actually able to deal with the systems
so it's a Kangol it tells you about
everything that's real
unlike the as design state so that's
when I realize it's far more important
to learn from incidents than to talk
about or preach about what we should do
to fix improve resiliency in production
so that's what I ended up doing I spent
a number of weeks over a period of time
starting last summer and then repeated
in during the December break again
during the July 4th break this year I
took a look look at over 1500 incidents
that happened at experia group these are
productions incidents I happen to have
data of how much how long it took to
recover and what happened in some cases
and and how much revenue loss or how
much impact the customer impact covers
caused by those incidents so I had this
data and and the complexity of all that
is that there are thousands of
applications running in multiple cloud
regions multiple data centers different
architectures none of it is consistent
running in one way the multiple systems
built over a period of time so I do
understand how those systems are what
those systems are telling so I can
actually help improve availability and
reduce a customer impact so that's what
I did
over a period of time and this is what I
found from that study of incidents
surprised then about half the impact was
due to changes that are we are making in
production systems either a changes in
progress or was recently made this is
not a surprise because you must have
experienced the same thing in your own
enterprises as well and if you look at
the publicly made incident reports by
Facebook Google and other companies over
the over years you will find the same
pattern every way a config change or a
code change made somewhere some impact
cost
like to a customer a customer incident
and you take time to recover from that
in in the case of the sample I took
about half the impact was caused because
of that sure counseling can not help
this situation I have a different
problem at hand
that's the realization I had the second
observation again this is based on
incident logs as a part of my study I
also looked at the slack logs sometimes
that was very manual exercise but I need
a book that just to understand how
people are behaving reading dealing with
the incident what I realized is that
because of the explosion of the number
of components running in any enterprise
tray it's fairly I mean even a young
company like Kenya sole company you have
thousands of systems running already in
production and we are running we are all
twenty years old company so what the
reality is looks like that you have some
tech debt that you can't get it up you
all have that you have some retired apps
that you don't know if you'd shut off or
not you have some monoliths they haven't
fully gotten rid of them we are
transitioning but you gotta leave them
and they have thousands of micro sizes
that you are changing all the time so as
a developer as an engineer or even even
if you're carrying a pager you probably
know what is so well about your
application and your neighborhood around
you but not a lot about second order
third order systems are depend on you or
the ones that you depend on so this
actually makes incidents hard to deal
with because you don't expect an outage
of your chain because of changes
something five layers elsewhere so this
makes it difficult to troubleshoot
incidents again a natural consequence of
complexity the third observation that I
had was that we don't understand where a
failure stops for example if there is a
an application in one datacenter that
fade would it impact another application
at the data center you don't know you
don't know because oftentimes we don't
maintain clear fault lines between
between in the in our applications so
what happens when you have a failure in
one part of that system you may have a
cascading failure elsewhere that you
least expect them and that leads to long
recovery times so those are three
observations I made out of these insert
analysis and in fact you go to my blog
at su Buddha or you will find a much
more detailed analysis report of the
findings feel free to check it out and
so what do these three observations tell
us first of all improve release safety
through progressive delivery again we
know this but two years ago before this
analysis before they know it's aside
about incidents when I asked teams
hey how about doing progressively
instead of pushing your code at the same
time to multiple flow regions how could
we stagger the release or a period of
time and people looked at as I'm crazy
because wonder slows down yes it would
slow you don't what makes this makes it
safe to laze in the production now that
I have data to showing that if over 50
percent of impact is because of changes
I get a I get a negative listening
people listen to what I am saying
because I have data to show that this
stuff is important the second observer
second point is that you have to have
stronger failure failure
domains failure boundaries in the design
itself you got to make sure that there
is redundancy and isolation between your
components of your system we can't have
dependencies crisscrossing with multiple
datacenters and deviations then you have
a leaky fall domains and things cascade
quickly so you have to invest in the as
design state the third is you have to
have implement safety again we know this
but we don't necessarily come back to
these ideas unless you see the data
about incidents
how do you get safety in production of
course nothing nothing phenomenon you
shed traffic when there is an incident
so you can actually preserve important
traffic you build independence
independent fall domains we used to call
this D or in the past which is nothing
but having a separate copy of the
application so you can actually failover
to that when there is something wrong so
you want at least two or more of those
fall domains for your critical
applications
you want to be able to shift traffic
away when there is a failure in one case
because if you want to recover from an
incident at cascading incidents in
minutes you better have a second copy
that is working healthy so you can shift
traffic because fixing a fire fighting
an incident is hard it takes time and of
course for this record Degas and follow
that nothing new here these are the
technologies that we all learned over 20
years in the operating internet scale
systems but the incidents really tell
you that you got to be good at these
basics and after doing all these three
is then you think of how do you break
systems because because you already
built safety into your systems then you
can make hypotheses about what can
happen this is in fact what happened to
me right at work today we have many of
our teams practicing multi-nation
fellows because we had incidents where
we want to recover little minutes and
then having this kind of investments
into safety helped us precisely do that
give an example I was on slack two
weekends ago when the AWS a zeal outage
happened in u.s. East one and one of my
team our teammates was saying I don't
care because we already tested all 53
between vs East one and us West - no
sweat because the team is already
invested in that process tested it and
it is working there's a consequence of
investing in safety before you try
breaking stuff but then how do you make
the case for these kind of failures this
is the hardest part
and he gave an example last year about
year and year 15 months ago we had a
long debate might that happen over many
weeks the point of contingent contention
was should we as part of cloud migration
should we build a second region with for
some of the critical components and
invest in failure testing before we call
it done and then we had both sides
arguing on side saying yeah we should do
it because it's the right thing to do
for customers and yada yada yada
and the other side saying well if you do
that it's going to cost this much more
because you have a second copy running
in production in a second region let's
go take this much time because you know
we have to implement this automation
failover replication all that stuff and
then one of my colleagues said you know
he actually pulled out some did some
math on there on a piece of paper how
much money do we make or revenue we get
over a period of time and then how much
this line of business gets okay this
suppose this person is we have some
dollar number and then how much
translate on average per minute okay we
have this number and see ask ourselves
how many minutes of downtime can we can
really survive can we accept can we
tolerate once looking at these numbers
three folks said yeah fifteen minutes
probably the max we should do shouldn't
going beyond that doesn't look good okay
what do you do 15 minutes recovering
from an incident okay you got to have a
second copy somewhere else
you need to have that second region
running then you can do it better so
focusing on value instead of the anxiety
of wanting to do this and it helped us
shift the focus to okay how do we
actually create that value for the
customer and then use that argument to
actually invest in this because for
people making priority decisions on what
to invest on what to invest the team
capacity for it is important to have
this data now once you have this kind of
data the your product people are you
leadership can make a decision okay
should I invest in that feature that
gets you X amount of money or does this
for the customer versus this thing that
actually saves from reduce the impact to
the customers then you can make an Apple
status comparison otherwise you end up
arguing for this can
hygiene investments and you won't get
prioritized lately so how did we get out
of the valley of misery one is learn
from incidents so instead of focusing on
the as designed state focus on as it is
named and see what those incidents are
telling you followed by making valued
based decisions because just because it
is good to do doesn't mean that you
should do it everywhere you have to
focus on where it makes more sense to do
that what kind of work so you pick up
your most critical systems that's where
you try it out
but that's where you also have to enlist
well up front for safety so you can
actually be mostly that kind of recovery
in minutes like like the example I cited
the most important question is that how
do you actually learn from incidents
there is no textbook Delta tells you how
to plan from incidents in fact this
field is so nice it the common pattern
that we all have is that incidents are
bad and sinner incidents are not
supposed to happen and we repeat an
incident as though they happen because
somebody or something or someone did not
do as it's supposed to has he or she or
it is not supposed to do somebody had a
bug that caused it
somebody pushed a change that caused it
something broke down the network the
vendor caused it that's how we think of
insert as though they are not supposed
to happen so there's no clear way to
figure out how do you become from is
learn from incidents what do we do when
we have an incident we look at the
impact and say can we write a
post-mortem
that's a chore we take it as a chore
because we want to get done quickly
so we can turn our attention back to our
sprint work and keep moving so we think
of incidents as though they are not
supposed to happen
so we don't spend enough time after
incidents to actually process and learn
from what is happening in our production
environments but how do you do this I
really don't know how to do that I did
one way but I am sure other companies
are trying different ways to learn from
it
but I can tell you something how does it
feel when you learn from incidents when
you have learned from the science and we
can describe this way you have better
mental models how the system works when
it does and how that it does not when it
does not that is you are able to look at
the system as a whole and they would
explain whether it is your architecture
whether it's your legacy components or a
lack of investments in certain areas our
tools processes and culture you can
actually make sense of these things when
you learn from you learn from incidents
and you're not chasing symptoms but are
beginning to understand the system as a
whole that's how I felt it when I looked
at incidents because it told me that we
got invest in change safety really
safety as a number-one thing and that
this data helped a lot of teams
recognize that they need to be diligent
about release safety having pipelines
that actually can roll back quickly and
those kind of improvements so you're not
chasing incidents you are actually
understanding the system as a whole the
third you understand the role of people
process and tools that play the tone of
the leader might use the tone a team
lead might use a manager might use after
an incident has an impact on whether we
are learning from incidents are we are
thinking of incidents as though they're
not supposed to happen and the bad for
us and somebody made a mix mistake so
you could create a period political
culture or a learning culture and a
learning culture will actually let you
learn through incidents and then you can
make systemic improvements so you start
to understand where you need to tweak
your approaches so you can actually get
the most sort of incidents and then you
articulate you you're able to articulate
the value of hygiene investments
I give I'll give another example of this
value hypothesis let's say you have a
monolith that's that you're able release
maybe twice a month which is not
uncommon for large enterprises with big
monoliths where the code gets sits in a
train and then at the end of 15 days or
two weeks release meeting team take
sad and then test six off test it and
then push it to production over let's
say or the weekend at midnight that
still happens for a lot of large
enterprises and now you want to put a
change in that you wanna introduce a
feature into that and that act that
piece that piece of functionality and
then take six months to introduce a
feature in six months are many releases
do you make six hundred to fall releases
that means you have the opportunity to
learn at most full time from changes you
are making that's as fast as you can go
because we know that getting feedback
from production systems is important so
you want to release in small batches and
that's why we do micro services but now
you have a choice to make
should I break out my core out of that
mono layton and do it quickly or stay in
the monolith get the figured release
done oftentimes we actually do the later
we stay in the monolith keep on pushing
code to it because you gotta get it done
we don't have time to refactor but if
you imagine if you refactor it takes
three months to refactor and then you
are making five releases a week you're
able to make a lot more releases in the
aggregate that means you're able to
create value quicker and quicker because
you you reduce the time to value from
two weeks to one day so making these
kind of arguments is important for
engineers because otherwise nobody will
understand nobody will prioritize this
kind of work and we had the closest
insist to the system that we're running
in the production so what is the lesson
from all this talk number one learn from
incidents don't treat incidents as
though they're not supposed to happen in
fact increase the time after an incident
to learn from what is going on in Cal
cated learning culture and that is the
number one thing that I said if you're
if you're Kairos nearing program must
succeed the most important thing to do
is listen to what incidents are telling
us number two there's no less there is
no number two that's the only lesson
thank you for the laughter thank you
very much and I think we have some time
for questions so there's no microphone
but I will be I will be repeat the
questions and then go ahead please
[Music]
yeah
so the question is are you actually
testing things after an incident and and
then are you doing the incident so that
you are actually getting better at over
time I think absolutely what what I have
seen over all this time is that the
teams that are paying attention to
incidents in fact this analysis I
published when they published internally
late last year and again multiple times
in increments internally it leads up a
lot of themes teams realize holy crap
this is what is happening let us go back
and look at our own systems so teams
have done their own analysis fitting
their own T data application system and
then realized where the opportunities
are some teams invested in in in having
the tendency and then were testing paler
was between region fellows and things
like that the other teams we said okay
we got to fix our pipelines so that we
can actually roll back quickly so it's a
so each team took the time to look at
their own systems and and figure out
what they need to invest in to get this
get this going so it's an organic moment
instead of a a systemic top-down mandate
of hey we got to do this right now
so we never had that kind of mandate
it's more organic based on the data I
think that actually worked out better
because people felt more passionate
about what they're doing and the value
their trading to this work yes please
this is this is a tough one I think I
think over time I realize that I think
the systems are complex the most
production environments are complex
because of the number of changes we make
the number of components we have very
few enterprises have the green field we
always operate in a gray field where you
have some young systems and old systems
and and none of us are long enough to
know all of it all over all of the
systems is humanly impossible once you
realize that our systems are reasonably
complex we don't understand enough of
what's happening in production we know a
little bit here and there I know my the
code I wrote but not the code my
teammates are writing I haven't
understood yet I feel very understanding
of what they're doing but I don't fully
understand all the assumptions they're
making so once you realize that we are
making different assumptions about how
different systems are supposed to work
and we are designing and implementing
based on those assumptions then your
attitude starts to change and as our
assumptions can be wrong and we of
course won't improve our assumptions but
we make assumptions and this is in fact
what is happening in in the with the
proliferation of micro service and other
assistance because we are making more
and more assumptions about the layers we
depend on the layers that we do that lie
on us they're kind of assumptions and so
those could go wrong and and then I
think once you take that approach it
becomes easy to say that it's not
actually it's humanly impossible to
understand and make sure everything is
done right what we can improve is the
culture and process and tools so we can
actually catch things sooner and have
the ability to react to the situations
quickly I'll give an example I was
talking to a friend of mine close friend
of mine about a year ago who joined a
large cloud company in the Seattle area
and the part of this the dating ban says
a bunch of new systems and they were
they scaled whoever rapidly and most of
the team members are either fresh out of
college or are really new to the team
they are all carrying pages and I this
friend used to carry laptop and he
to come to our house on evenings I
quoted by the laptop although I'm
impatient you don't call this weekend
so they'll stress obviously and I'm
making a border a few just at the other
weekend we were hiking and I asked him
how are things going
he said Kim so much better he was on
page really but I think I'm much better
I said what changed
did you refactor Raymond something you
did something better
classically he said no it just we got
used to it we actually know much more
about our systems now so you can they
act quickly so in a sense what he's
telling is the reaction learn a lot from
the post model we are writing we have a
better sense of what is going on so we
can actually quickly tell and time is a
good such good good subject good creates
an opportunity to learn from systems so
there's some drastic change without
without actually messing anything in
production so that's the consequence of
learning I think I think I believe in
that process I think the if we stop
thinking of incidents as they are not
supposed to happen and so they're a
consequence of reality in the world then
we have a much better control I think
any other questions at the back yes
please
the very important question the question
is that how do you ensure that after an
incident you have a post mortem and you
have identified a number of action items
how do you ensure that actually teams
are actually doing all that no I don't
ensure that and here's why
if the EM can give you an exaggerated
example let's say you you have an
incident once a week not uncommon in
that systems it happens and then you
have a team of 20 30 people and so and
if you have an incident every week and
you have five six items from that from
that incident post mortem to work on
over time your backlog fills up and you
don't get the time to you not have the
time to act on all those backlog items
and fields it feels it feels bad because
you're not taking care of hygiene the
things you said you want to do you're
not actually getting the time to do them
because you are a feature work that's
piling on you and so I think I think
instead of worrying about fixing all
items how would actually look for
patterns and look at the value and once
you shift shift your focus words are
there patterns that I can actually look
at of all the incident maybe every month
or two months you sit down and look at
all your incidents but there are there
patterns between those incidents are
they among things that actually in
listen to improve what is going on and
then while you do the Riggin Altos in
see which of those things actually
reduce the customer impact so you look
at systemic systemically like what you
could do instead of going after each
incident because you'll have you will
not have enough time to go after each
instance fix everything that you need to
fix but if you look at patterns my
hypothesis is that you will have the
opportunity to study what improvements
you need to make and then how much value
those improvements will provide and then
you can actually argue for getting those
investments made I think instead of so
that's that's the way I look at it look
at our C outcomes I mean after I'm sure
there are different perspectives on this
but this how I'm learning to see this
yes please
ab-absolutely because it becomes real
because then you know what assumptions
that that need to be tested because you
already built this enough safety into
your system but you still want to make
sure they are being tested so let's say
we have traffic peak times in through
air in any e-commerce companies you have
traffic Peaks and we don't want to make
sure that our systems actually meet the
traffic so we go through tests of okay
are the auto scaling groups working as
expected
are we able to shift traffic if we have
to so you go through those exercises to
prepare your systems for the real world
so there is still value but it's not
just isolated it sound connected in the
same scheme of things of how do i
improve stability how do I get more sort
of incidents and things like that any
other questions I think we have one more
minute
if not thank you very very much
I'll give that this time
[Applause]